Speaker 1: Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
tried taking the high road against Donald
Trump's recent attack on him. And while I
admire DeSantis, I guess in some vague way
for not stooping to Trump's level. DeSantis
will lose if this is his approach. It didn't
work for any of these Republicans in 2016.
It's not going to work for Ron DeSantis. So
let's take a look at this clip. The context here,
I will remind you, is that Donald Trump published
two truths Social Truth.
Speaker 2: Essential.
Speaker 1: A picture of Ron DeSantis with some
allegedly high school girls Retro Thing, a message
that argued that Ron was grooming high school
girls. Donald Trump posting. That's not Ron,
is it? He would never do such a thing. Ron
DeSantis was asked about this. He attempted
to take the high road. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: I spend my time delivering
results for the people of Florida and fighting
against Joe Biden. That's how I spend my time.
I don't spend my time trying
to smear other Republicans now.
Speaker 1: Uh oh. How great, Ron. Really, really
great. You took the high road. You will lose if
this is what you do. He doesn't have a chance
in hell of defeating Donald Trump. If that is
going to be his approach, it's not what Republican
voters want to see at this point. He's going with
the I'm above this sort of approach on this
thing. And they tried it in 2016. It did not
work. It might have gotten you two, three, four,
five, six, 7%. But then Trump consolidated support
and consolidated and consolidated. DeSantis
does have the possibility of defeating Donald
Trump in a 2024 primary. DeSantis hasn't even
announced that he is running at this point,
and he's polling really well against the
former president when he hasn't even said,
I am actually a candidate for this office.
This is not about DeSantis can't win. But
think back to couple weeks ago, a month ago,
a month ago, two months ago, when I told you
polling aside. I don't know that DeSantis,
constitutionally, personality wise, has what it
takes to go up against Trump and Trump's nicknames
and Trump's insults in a national campaign. I
don't know whether DeSantis has it in him. The
fact that he is already going with I'm above
this stuff. I'm not going around criticizing other
Republicans. I don't waste my time on this sort of
thing. There is not a chance in hell that DeSantis
wins with that approach. If you disagree with me,
I want to hear from you. I just don't see it. And
part of the reason why is that these Republican
voters, many of these Republican voters, they
don't want unity and decorum and the right tone
or any of this stuff. They voted for Trump, but
they voted for the guy who said grab him by the
you know, what was drawing stuff with sharpies and
said that woman's not attractive enough for me to
ever have sexually assaulted her. They don't
want little Marco and Ted Cruz. His wife is
ugly and all this different stuff. That's what
they wanted. That's what they voted for. And
while many of them will tell you, oh, I want
to return to civility and all these things,
and some of them genuinely do want that. The
Romney esque ones. Most of them don't. Most of
them want that alpha energy that they claim comes
from Donald Trump. And they're not going to go for
this. So if this is the Santos approach, he is
dead in the water on this campaign. That hasn't
even started yet. Disagree with me. Let me know.
Agree with me. I want to hear from you as well.